brit forest congratulations the strength
of your tactical blades has landed you
in the third and final round of this
competition which means that you're both
four short forging days shy of the title
of forest and fire champion and that
check for ten thousand dollars all you
need to do now is make one of these
a halogen bar
it is an iconic rescue tool and here to
tell you more about it is captain brian
olith
the haligan bar to the modern fire
service is the multi-purpose tool it is
probably the most important tool that's
carried on a fire truck besides water
and hose and the firefighters themselves
good luck we'll see you in four days
good luck brother all right
[Music]
today i'm going to start forging the
halogen i'm going to start at the fork
in and just work my way back
my plan for construction on this halogen
is forge weld damascus build not only is
that going to add strength but it will
lend a considerable amount of aesthetic
value to this
is this enough steel
yeah
[Music]
the pressure of being a retired fireman
and being tasked with making the very
first halogen on force and fire that
situation is not lost on me by any means
if i think about it too much i can
probably put a lot of pressure on myself
but what i have control over is my
design and i'm gonna do it the best that
i can
this day is over
beginning of day two let's get that
steel hot beat the hell out of it
what we're gonna do today is we're going
to work on forming the adds we're going
to stretch out the handle
right now we're just getting that handle
stretched out to give us our length for
firefighters you're going to want
something with some heft to it to grip
it so i'm just coming in here and i'm
squashing my corners
to give it a an octagonal shape
it's really looking like it's supposed
to i'm going to do some grinding and
clean up and make sure i don't have any
coal shut
got a lot done today i'm down to forging
out the forks and a little bit of
straightening and then onto heat treat
really feeling good about it
life is good life is good
day three i'm ready to get this thing
forged and get it quenched
get my forks pretty well shaped up
start forging that pie count and it's
looking good
so now it's time to drip the hole for
the pike there we go
all right that's a biggie now all we
have to do is get the ads into place
and uh we're ready to clench
get things up to heat
go ahead put it in the quench tank
and i've got too little oil oh that's
not good
so now i've got an incomplete quench
the only part that's really not hard is
the really important part like the adds
and the pike they're gonna
re-quench on that everything's riding on
this being right
this doesn't work i'm screwed
[Music]
much better it's actually a really good
quench i'm happy it's a good thing i'm
retired because i don't know that i ever
want to see a halligan again
beginning of day four today we're gonna
forge out the forks
and there you have it boys and girls
let's heat treat it this is hands down
the largest tool i've ever quenched so
what we're going to end up doing is
we're going to heat treat the front half
flip it around heat treat the second
half
let's quench this beast
she's straight i see no cracks let's
quench the other half three two
one
we have a successful quench
[Music]
so
what we're gonna do
is simulate a breach
i'll say it works bladesmiths welcome to
the car crash extraction test
to test your haligan bars we're going to
take your haligan bar and try to rescue
this dummy inside this crashed car now
this is all about how well your haligan
bars perform it's time to find out if
your haligan bars
will rescue
to test your haligan bars i'd like to
introduce firefighters jim and carl
welcome gentlemen rip your first you
ready
grip it and rip it
hit
hit
hit
nice
all right brit let's talk about your
haligan bar here based on the
firefighter's feedback first up the bar
it's a little bit heavier but it's
manageable when it comes to your spike
and your ads over here they function
quite well and they got the job done
overall sir
it will rescue like sure okay forest
your turns are you ready well we didn't
get dressed up for nothing
clear
[Music]
[Music]
hit
hit
hit
hit
hit it again
hit
it
all right forest talking about your
haligan bar here first up it's a lighter
weight so it's easier to carry
now the adds over here did not penetrate
nicely inside and the reason for that is
you don't have a flat surface here not
having a flat surface here when you're
making impact it kind of shears off to
the side but it was effective it worked
and more importantly
it will rescue congratulations gentlemen
your halogen bars have passed our first
test so now we've turned up the heat
this is our flaming tower test now to
test your haligan bars firefighters
steve and captain john are going to take
them and break through this training
door once they're through that door
they'll go up three flights of stairs
use your halogen tool again to bust out
that window to assist in the rescue now
no one really knows what's gonna happen
in a rescue situation so to test that
halogen tool one more time we're gonna
drop it from that three-story window
awesome
all right brett are you ready
let's break it
hey
[Music]
finally
the biggest thing was the forks they're
a little too thick
so brit first off your ads worked very
nicely but the width of your forks was
an issue since they're so thick right
here captain had a hard time getting
that into that door jamb when every
second counts you want that to pass
right through but overall performed well
took the fall like a champ good job
thank you sir
all right forrest you're up now you
ready yes sir
good
[Applause]
[Music]
this hitting surface could be a little
bit bigger right
guys tend to miss it a little bit
so forest right off the damascus was a
nice touch the forks got into that door
really easily but
this corner should be sort of a 90
degree with flats the axe kind of slid
off a few times and you really want a
good driving surface on this but all in
all it survived good job well done thank
you
brit forest this has been an extremely
tough competition for the first time
ever we asked smiths to go back to their
home forges and make something other
than a weapon and you've both proven
that your haligan tools are forged in
fire tough however
only one of you can be the forged and
fire champion and that champion is brit
congratulations you're the foreign fire
champion
forrest unfortunately your haligan tool
didn't make the cut
well forrest you brought us an
attractive and functional rescue tool
however its lack of a defined corner
with flat striking surfaces cause it to
be a little less effective than your
competitors
and that's why we're letting you go
it's all right
forest you made a beautiful damascus
haligan to it but at this time you're
dismissed from the training area
good job brother good job brit and mine
both performed well it just came down to
some very minor design decisions and
brit made some better decisions than i
did
i'm exceptionally proud of the fact of
being able to represent the fire
department sorry i didn't come out on
top guys but you know what we gave her a
hell of a good go
britt congratulations you are the force
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with check for ten thousand
dollars good job man thank you sir thank
you i am the forest and fire champion
and it feels amazing i came here
confident that i had a pretty good shot
forest comes from the fire service side
i come from the law enforcement side i
thought he made a beautiful tool i
simply just made a slightly better tool
than he did and brought the win
you